- I really didn't-
I really didn't look at
myself as a successful person.
I didn't see the things that
other people see, you know?
And then when I did, you
know, I was a narcissict
and I was stuck up and-
You know, I've never been able
to have a happy medium ever.
I know the one good thing
that I was good at is
being a mom.
I was a good mom.
And that's part of the-
That's part of the reason
why I get hurt so much out here, you know?
Because I think that I'm trying to
mother so many other people, you know?
And take them underneath my
wing and then they hurt me,
or rob me or both, you know?
And then next thing you know, I'm like,
"Oh my god, I believed in you.
I believed in you when
you didn't believe in you.
And this is how you repay me?"
But hey, it is what it is
and it ain't what it ain't.
Just like you said, not
everybody is capable.
And there is good and
there is evil out here,
and I just so happen to be
somebody that has good in them still.
- [Mark] You clearly had it at
one point in your life.
And maybe you're losing your kids
sent you spiraling downward but-
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] But that doesn't
mean you can't get it back.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] And with a little help,
a little housing, a little-
- Right, it only took
three years in Skid Row
and all kinds of-
- [Mark] But you're
using Crystal Meth less,
are you using Crystal Meth at all anymore?
- Not at all.
- [Mark] And you're
drinking a lot less, right?
- A lot less.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm trying.
- [Mark] That's great.
Because when I-
when, I'm not gonna say if,
when I do get off the streets, right?
I don't want the detox
process to be so painful,
because I have detox from
alcohol, and it's very painful.
You get restless leg syndrome,
you feel anxiety, you sweat, you shake.
It's pretty bad.
So I don't want it to be so painful,
because I've already wasted so much time
on the street.
And this Bermuda Triangle
of fuckin' Skid, bro.
I swear it's Bermuda Triangle.
- [Mark] It really is.
- You fly over this bitch
and you'll never be seen again ever.
Like I had said before, I'm
not going out like that.
I'll be damned, I'll be damned.
And because I do have a daughter, right?
And she's almost the same age that I was.
I would really like to be in her life.
I don't want any of those
things to happen to her
that happened to me.
And even though my mom
is not the same person,
she's still evil enough to
take my kids away from me
and not let me see them,
knowing that that would ruin me.
For a paycheck?
They need me.
They need me, especially my baby girl.
Boys need their moms too.
But little girls
especially need their moms.
- [Mark] How old are your kids?
- Three, 11, and 14.
Jeremiah, Therese, and Christopher.
Those are my babies.
I named them all after something.
Because I believe that
your name has power.
At least I believe that.
That Christopher means with
Christ inside your heart,
so I named him that, and
he's just the sweetest boy.
He looks like I climbed on top of myself
and got pregnant my son.
He's got big green eyes, just like me.
And he has the sweetest spirit.
And my daughter-
My daughter's my little chocolate drop.
And she looks just like me but black.
Therese means reaper,
like you know how it says
you reap what you sew.
Not reaper like Grim Reaper,
but reaper like receiver.
And that's also my mother's name,
'cause my mother named
me after her mother.
So I wanted to keep the
legacy going, I guess.
Jeremiah is named after
a Prophet in the Bible.
And he is a mighty little boy.
He was nine pounds, 22 and a half inches.
They had to give me an
emergency c-section,
because my heart rate was
excelling and his heart rate was dropping.
So they were basically losing both of us.
So they had to give me
an emergency c-section.
That was my little miracle baby,
that was my silver baby, that was my...
Yeah.
- [Mark] So you've been
on the street for how long now?
- Three years.
- [Mark] Three years?
And you've been through it all,
you've been beaten up, you've been-
- Raped, robbed, kidnapped.
- [Mark] Tipped?
- Yes.
All of that.
- [Mark] And you're finally climbing out.
Or you're ready to climb out.
- Absolutely.
Absolutely, absolutely.
I can not, I can not do this anymore.
- [Mark] That's what I was saying earlier,
that I don't believe the majority
of the people interviewed
are even capable of accepting.
Let's say we did a donation campaign
for most of the people
that I talk to and say,
"Here we're gonna get you housing,
we're gonna get you rehab,
we're gonna get you this,
that and the other."
I don't believe those
people would actually
be able to use it.
- They are very comfortable.
- [Mark] Unless they want it more than
everyone else in their life combined,
they're just gonna find some
excuse why it's not working.
- They've given up.
- [Mark] And you-
or I'm hearing in your voice is
you want this more than I do.
You want-
- Yeah 'cause it's for
me, it ain't for you.
- [Mark] Yeah, and that's
the important part.
Because I can want it and
my viewers can want it
as much as you deserve it,
but if you don't want it-
- I want it.
- [Mark] What are we doing?
And that's why you're back
'cause I see that you actually
are capable and ready to do something.
- I have to.
I have to, because at this point,
because good things are
happening in my life.
So that means that the good
is outweighing the bad now.
So now the tables have been turned and,
just like God will never
stop fighting for me,
the Devil won't either.
'Cause in all actuality
I'm valuable to both teams,
even though that sounds bad, it's true.
So it's spiritual warfare in
there, both fighting for me.
But I can not let the
Devil win, and I won't.
I won't.
I was bought with a price a long time ago,
and I'll never forget that.
What I did see
with a lot of the comments
that I read, right?
- [Mark] Just in case.
- Thank you, sweetheart.
What I did see with a lot
of the comments that I read,
and there were a lot of comments,
I thank all of you guys
for believing in me
and for wanting to hug me
and for wanting to help me
and for your words of encouragement.
Because I-
There were days where I would
just read all the comments,
and I would remind myself,
that okay you know what?
If all these people in Australia
and Canada and Mississippi
and everywhere else,
if they can believe in you, why can't you?
Right?
- [Mark] That's exactly right.
- So I had to just keep reading.
- [Mark] It's a really good sign
when somebody I interview reads
or even engages in the comments.
Because there have been
people who I've interviewed,
who everyone thinks they're
communicating with this person,
but I know for a fact that
person refuses to read
all the positive comments that are coming.
- I tried to like all of them,
but there's like-
- [Mark] No, no, no-
- There's like 1,200 or something like-
- [Mark] No, you can't like them all.
But just reading them,
and I've seen this very
often where people-
there's a sea of positivity
coming there way.
Love, compassion, positivity.
And they won't even read it,
because it doesn't fit into
their negative mindset.
Their self hate.
So why would I wanna read this positivity,
these people that are saying all these
lovely, wonderful things,
loving things towards me.
It doesn't fit their self image,
so they're gonna reject it.
- When my-
- [Mark] Or ignore it.
- Right, but when my old job, right?
And people that I hung out with,
got drunk with and worked
with for years, right?
One of the girls that got ahold of me
is my daughters god mom.
And she's actually a
co-owner of the company
that I used to work for, for years, right?
And this is a company-
One of the only companies
that actually believed in me
and dealt with my bullshit.
But because I'm very good at my job-
- [Mark] Your bullshit
being, like the alcohol?
- Yeah, because I've been struggling
with this off and on for a long time.
Not just the alcohol but my temper and my
sense of entitlement.
All that stuff comes along
with addiction, it really does.
Especially when you find something
that you're finally good at.
You get cocky and all that other stuff.
I was really good at my job,
so I felt like I was King Kong.
So they dealt with me going
off on the sales floor
and all of that stuff.
Having no call no shows,
just stupid stuff that any
other job would fire you for.
They knew me when I had
first had my baby, my oldest.
I actually, because my
babysitter had flaked on me,
this is a long time ago,
this is like in 2005.
My babysitter flaked on me,
so I had to bring my baby
with me to my interview.
From that point on,
they just fell in love with me,
and I had two more kids
while I was in the company
and everything else.
They actually even opened up
another company in Colombia.
There's good things going on.
And they want me to be a part of it again.
But everybody has their own
lives and their own shit
and their own bills to pay.
Car payments and all that, you know?
It's hard to take on a
whole another person.
I know for sure that if you could do it,
I know that you would.
You know what I mean?
If you could financially say,
"Aye, hey, look, here's this place,
we're taking you here,
you're gonna work there."
I know that you would
do that if you could.
But that's hard to do.
Especially if you don't know for sure,
you have to see that
somebody is gonna try.
You have to know.
I appreciate you very much, you know?
I've never had a perfect stranger
help me the way that you've helped me.
My own family has even abandoned me.
And I never understood
how much seeing yourself
in your own mess could change your outlook
on what's going on, really around you.
You know how they have that saying:
On the outside lookin' in.
I actually got to do that,
and I used to watch my video,
and it would make me
cry every single time.
It was therapeutic to me, and
I appreciate you for that.
This is not a game, this is not a game.
This is not truth or dare,
this is not a story, this
is not fuckin' make believe,
this is not fiction.
This is my life, and I do
not wanna lose it out here.
'Cause one of two things are
gonna happen, Mark, 'kay?
Because I've been trying my hardest
to have so much compassion, and I do.
But like I had said in
my previous interview,
because of all the crap that
I've been going through,
and all the heartache and all the pain
and all the everything.
Like believing in people
and people hurting me
and all that stuff, it's made me meaner.
So I'm either gonna hurt somebody,
like for real, for real
and go to prison for the rest of my life.
Because I have all this
built of aggression
on the inside of me.
So if I were to ever just go off,
oh my god, it would
probably be bad, you know?
Especially the way that I was drinking,
'cause you know, at that point
you get inebriated, right?
And then you're emotion are...
They're heightened, you know?
And you can start off just
a little bit pissed off,
but if you drunk enough,
oh you turn into the motherfuckin' Hulk.
You know what I mean?
I don't wanna hurt anybody,
and I'm tired of being hurt.
So I really feel in my heart
that I'm being released
from Skid Row.
I do.
Because I know that there
was I reason why I was here.
And not to toot my own
horn or anything like that,
but I have touched a lot of people.
Whether it was good or bad or indifferent.
These motherfuckers are gonna remember me.
Do you know what I mean?
They will.
They'll remember me.
And I will remember
every single one of them,
and I hope that one day,
after I get outta here,
matter of fact I know that
I'm gonna come back here.
I'm gonna give back.
'Cause ironically enough,
before I even came out here,
I used to feed the
homeless on Thanksgiving.
And now I'm the one being
fed on Thanksgiving.
- [Mark] How's that feel?
- Fucked up.
(Mark chuckles)
'Cause I remember my first
Thanksgiving out here,
I just cried and cried
and cried and cried.
And these last two
Thanksgivings and Christmases
have been extra cold and
raining and messed up.
And everybody out here is a scavenger.
And these organizations don't really
have enough for everybody, you know?
- [Mark] I think a lot of my viewers
don't understand the number
of people that are out here.
- Oh god.
- [Mark] They see 200 videos on my channel
and think, "Oh my god, there's
200 people down there."
- Fuck no.
- [Mark] There's like 200,000,
and I'm just picking the ones
that are the most interesting.
- It's-
- [Mark] You know what they say,
"Once you help this person,
"what about the other 10,000
that are just like her?"
- Right.
- [Mark] Of that one person,
you think we're gonna help?
- Right.
- [Mark] You're ignoring the other 999-
(chuckles)
There's so many others
- Right.
- [Mark] That are just like her.
- Well, what they need to do is
they need to come and see for themselves.
- [Mark] And then again,
this goes on in every
state of the country.
Not to the same extent that it is here,
in maybe San Francisco and LA-
- Absolutely not.
- [Mark] Seattle, Portland,
all have really terrible
homeless communities,
but so does New York, New Jersey, Chicago.
- They have the river
in Orange County too.
The river bed people.
- [Mark] Yeah, so it's
all over the country,
and it's getting worse.
- But it's bad though, there's a lot.
And it's to an extreme,
because I believe that
this is where a lot of
all the crap originated from, you know?
You here all kinds of stories.
I heard a story from my OG the other day.
He had said, you know the reason-
'cause the rats are aggressive out here.
They're not just regular rats.
I call the rats gang bangers.
They're not regular rats.
And an older guy told me-
- [Mark] They're very bold.
- You know the reason why
they're bold like that
is because in the 80's we
were feeding them crack.
I said, "What, shut the hell up."
He said, "No, for real."
And if you look it up, even on YouTube,
and I looked it up on YouTube,
because I wanted to see
what he was talking about.
They've done experiments
on rats with crack cocaine.
And they will keep going
back for their crack.
Over and over and over again.
They get addicted very quickly.
And they're bigger than normal.
Mannn.
I was standing in front
of the store, right?
And I had just-
My friend had just bought me a hamburger,
and I was really hungry too.
And I took a bite of it, right?
And I put it on the
wall, I had wrapped it up
and put it on the wall,
because I had to tie my shoe
to fix my backpack, right.
This big rat came out
and just took my hamburger
off the wall, like even
the rats are scavengers.
Like even the rats are gang bangers.
They will bite holes in your tent.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- They will go in your
tent and eat your food.
Just when you think that everything's okay
and because you got all
these rat traps around.
No, they're hybrid rats or something,
like something's wrong.
It's crazy out here, it's crazy.
'Cause I'm ready to go.
I was not-
This is not the kind of life that I want.
- [Mark] I'm so happy to
hear you speak like this,
'cause last time we spoke,
you weren't really as
driven to change your situation.
- No, I really thought that
I was gonna die out here.
- [Mark] And that positivity, that...
readiness for success is, to me,
the most important part of recovery.
You need to want...
and just not just want,
but be driven to succeed.
And to be fulfilled and
to have a good life.
I hear that in your voice now.
You'll be the first...
addict that I'm involved in
doing a donation campaign for.
Because everything you're saying
tells me that you can do it.
- Yeah well-
- [Mark] Whereas everyone else I've spoken
to that's an addict,
they're ready to stay
right where they're at.
- They enjoy it.
- [Mark] They enjoy it,
they might say they want recovery.
- I don't even like to go
in other peoples tents.
The only time I go in anybody else's tent
is if it's clean or I'm
absolutely desperate.
- [Mark] No, you're coming around.
You're coming back to the world.
- Do you know what I mean?
And then I try to encourage others,
and they all have excuse
after excuse after excuse,
like I feel free, this is
freedom, I feel good out here.
And this man tell me the other day that
he left his dad's birthday party, right?
To go get a pack of cigarettes.
Ended up downtown and hasn't
been home in ten years.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You have a home that
you can go to right now,
and you're choosing methamphetamines,
and this nasty ass tent
with this dirty ass dog
over being home?
- [Mark] Because it
feels like home to them.
It feels like where they belong.
- Fuck-
- [Mark] And what's great about
listening to you talk today is
it's very clear that you feel
like you don't belong here any longer.
- I don't.
Fuck that shit, I wanna go back to work,
and I wanna start doing my nails again.
And feeling good about myself again,
because that's where I lost it at, Mark.
Because I lost my self worth.
- [Mark] That's how this happens.
- Right.
Because woman get discouraged, right?
And then these men keep
them all drugged up,
and all they wanna do is screw on 'em
and keep 'em locked up
in a tent, you know?
I've even seen woman
in cages before, Mark.
It's bad out here.
Nope, oh no, not me, I can't.
I can't, I can't.
Well, anyway one of the things that
a lot of the viewers wanted
to do was hear me sing.
- [Mark] I'd love to
hear you sing. (chuckles)
- Now that I'm on blast, I
don't even know what to sing.
Let me think.
Oh, here I got one.
This is from the movie
Fighting Temptations.
It's actually a Christian movie
and they have a choir or whatever.
Beyonce has a part that's awesome.
And I've actually sung this
while walking down the street before
in the middle of the night, cold as hell.
Because one thing-
music makes me happy.
Remember how I said in my last video,
"As long as I got my music and my alcohol
and my cigarettes, I'm straight."
As long as I have music,
because what it does is it
never lets me down, right?
It never lets me down and
it helps me feel, you know?
I'm no longer numb because
it's something that I love.
It's something I love.
So I will sing in the middle of the day,
in the middle of the night
at the top of my lungs.
I don't give a damn, I'm gonna sing.
But she says-
Especially because of
what she says, she says-
'Cuse me, I smoke a lot in Newports,
that's one thing I have not quit.
(chuckles)
She said,
♪ I used to wake up some days ♪
♪ And wish I'd stayed asleep ♪
♪ 'Cause I went to bed
on top of the world ♪
♪ Today the worlds on top of me ♪
♪ Everybody's got opinions ♪
♪ Y'all ain't been in my position ♪
♪ So I laugh at the world ♪
♪ When I hear what they
have to say about me ♪
♪ Feels like I always fall
short of bein' worthy ♪
♪ 'Cause I ain't good enough ♪
♪ But you still love me ♪
♪ I ain't no superstar ♪
♪ The spotlight ain't shinin' on me ♪
♪ 'Cause I ain't good enough ♪
♪ But you still love me ♪
♪ I'm not perfect ♪
♪ Yes I do wrong ♪
♪ I've been trying my best ♪
♪ But it ain't good enough ♪
♪ Shunned by the world ♪
♪ If I don't succeed ♪
♪ Though I ain't good enough ♪
♪ He still loves me ♪
- Man, that's like one
of my favorite songs.
- [Interviewer] All right, Niqi.
We're gonna do something
to help you out of there.
- All right.
What we gonna do?
You gotta help me up, I got hurt.
- [Mark] Good job.
- [Niqi] Thank you.
- [Mark] I'm proud of you.